[Music]
well this week a handful of women filed
a lawsuit against the state of Texas
over its abortion Ban Texas among 12
states with the most restrictive of
abortion rules we take a look at the
impact the Supreme Court's ruling in
June has had on women seeking assistance
with one online birth control provider
we also saw a bump in Texas Dr Sophie
again is the CEO of pandia Health the
only doctor-led birth control delivery
company business has skyrocketed since
the summer when the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade giving each state
the authority to set its own abortion
policies but I think women had a wake-up
call that if you can't access abortion
you better get your birth control under
control pandia Health automates that the
company delivers to 50 states its
Mission no one runs out of birth control
on its watch and it resonated with women
we saw the numbers go up three times and
we didn't expect that in liberal states
like New York where they have pharmacies
on every corner so they don't need us
but these days Dr Yen says it's the
important reminders about prescriptions
that are so valuable we remind you two
months before expires go see your doctor
one month before go see your doctor one
week before please see your doctor in 15
States including Nevada the experts with
pandia health can even write you a
prescription Dr Yen says in today's
world women have got to be be prepared
and protected if you suffered a bad
experience with side effects from the
pill in the past she says there are
plenty of options there are 40 40
different pills if you don't like one
there are 39 others please see a doctor
don't just give up and be like I tried
the pill bye-bye
Dr Yen adds it's wise to use two forms
of birth control